[Music]
you
[Music]
how just is the abstract independence of
Stoicism exhibited the process of its
actualization so to will this last form
of Independence that is personality
recapitulate the process of the first
form the former passes over into the
skeptical confusion of consciousness
into a negative rambling which lacking
in a stable form strain is fortuitously
from one form of being and thought to
another dissolving them it is true in
its absolute independence but no less
recreating them it is in fact merely the
contradiction of a consciousness which
is at once independent and dependent
personal independence in the sphere of
legal right is really a similar general
confusion and reciprocal dissolution of
this kind for what counts as an absolute
essential being is self-consciousness as
the sheer empty unit of the person in
contrast to this empty universality
substance is the form of fullness and
content and this content is now set free
and is unorganized for the spirit that
subdued it and held it together in its
unity is no longer present this empty
unit of the person is therefore in its
reality of contingent existence and
essentially a process and inaction that
comes to no lasting result
what skepticism the formalism of legal
right is thus by its very nature without
a peculiar content of its own it finds
before it a manifold existence in the
form of possession and a skepticism did
stamps it with the same abstract
universality whereby it is called
property but whereas in skepticism the
reality is so determined is called it a
loser reappearance and it is only a
negative value in legal right it has a
positive value that negative value
consists in the actual having the
significance of the self qua quality
implicit Universal the positive value in
the case of legal right however consists
in it being mined in the sense of the
category as something whose validity is
recognized an actual both are the same
abstract Universal the actual content or
the specific character of what is mine
whether it be an external possession
we're also the inner riches or poverty
of poverty of spirit and character is
not contained in this empty form and
does not concern it the content belongs
therefore to an autonomous power which
is something different from the formal
Universal to a power which is arbitrary
and capricious consciousness of right
therefore in the very fact of being
recognized as having validity
experiences rather than loss of its
reality in its complete innocence she
ality and to describe an individual as a
person is an expression of contempt
paragraph 480 is right at the heart of
this this short section legal right
which is only seven paragraphs long and
it's really quite an important
transition point after this we're going
to see Hegel talking about you might say
one of the the problems that comes about
in the world of legal right which which
has to do with the individual who gets
to matter or if you want to put it this
way using the previous discussions in
the earlier sections the government but
on the way there he is going to be
continuing this parallelism that he
sketched out in just the last paragraph
between what was happening in in
stoicism the way that Hegel interpreted
it and what is happening to the person
as such in this regime of legal right
this it's better to think of this not
just as a regime and such but but as a
way in which the entire ethical world is
being articulated it's a replacement for
what had come before it and it's also
you know to use Hegel's term with
sublation of it progresses beyond it but
it doesn't feel exactly like a progress
and here in this section Hegel is going
to add another wrinkle to it he's going
to bring up the stage of that or the
shape of consciousness that followed
stoicism in his phenomenological
exposition of it not not actually
historically as such but but in terms of
the importance of thought by talking
about skepticism notice that he's not
yet talking about the unhappy
consciousness which is going to come in
in the next paragraph so Hegel sees a
parallelism of development occurring
between what had happened in the self
consciousness section with the
development of self consciousness
first moving the stoicism which he
talked about like I said in the previous
paragraph so it's still going to talk
about a bit here but then talking about
skepticism he sees a parallelism between
that and what is happening with the
person in terms of legal right and the
way that it articulates the world and
this is a very rich paragraph there's a
lot going on here so there's a lot of
commentary required it's not merely a
long paragraph it's a dense one so Hegel
starts out by saying just as the
abstract independence of stoicism
exhibited the process of its
actualization what the the abstract
independence is actualization so to will
this last form of Independence that is
personality recapitulate the process of
the first form what does he mean thereby
the first form what was going on in the
self-consciousness section so he says
the former which is of course stoicism
passes over into the sceptical confusion
of consciousness and Hegel you know
gives us a new characterization of this
here but it's very similar to what he
spelled out in much greater detail in
the scepticism section he says a
negative rambling which lacking any
stable form strays fortuitously from one
form of being and thought to another
dissolving them it is true and it's
absolute independence but no less
recreating them so that's a very nice
and capsulation of what was taking place
in that that section of
self-consciousness notice that there's a
couple different things going on there
the he says that in skepticism as
opposed to in stoicism where the stoic
is asserting the independence of their
own self-consciousness visa vie the
world including it you know political
relations its power relations its
economic relations and is doing so in
terms of pure thought and by aligning
him or herself with these these you know
the true the good the rational Hegel
thinks that there's
sort of promise that's being held out
there that stoicism ultimately can't
deliver on and again let's remind
ourselves that we don't need to worry so
much about whether Hagel has stoicism
completely right we can certainly think
of many people who fit into the stoic
mindset in terms of popular culture or a
you know sort of not fully developed
conceptionist those who do fit Hegel's
Hegel's description there Hegel says
that this passes over into skepticism
and skepticism is you might say all over
the map as a matter of fact whereas
stoicism was able to have some sort of
coherent though ultimately not totally
adequate understanding of itself what's
really interesting with skepticism is
that it is you know a lot of people is a
little bit of a digression here we'll
come back to this and let me close the
sentence by saying what's really
interesting about skepticism is not that
it is self-defeating but that it is you
might say applying to itself in such a
tortured way so the digression now a lot
of people want to oppose skepticism by
thinking they can give it a knockout
blow by saying well if you're going to
say anything can be called into question
can't that be called into question too
and the skeptic can say yeah yeah
exactly buddy that that's a problem
that's not helping me refute the
condition that I'm in you're right
everything is refutable everything is
doubt about anything could have a
counter-argument presented to it
including that statement itself what the
hell am I going to do
and so you know from a practical point
of view skepticism is not going to be
refuted
so simply as some of the textbook
authors would like to do so it's a
genuine shape of consciousness according
to Hegel now notice what he has to say
about it let's let's go over this a
little bit more closely call this a
confusion of consciousness fear all
right a going astray
this is this is a a composite term when
you've got the fair kind of like an
intensifier but it also it already
involves a like things going wrong and
iran means you know going it's what we
it's a cognate to airing for us right
so like a we might translate it as trans
earring in a trans earring right going
astray so far that you're not even sure
how the hell you got there right
skepticism is in a certain way like
being lost and being lost so thoroughly
that you're not even sure what map you
might need to consult let alone where
you are on the map and at the same time
you still have content you still have a
map you still have things in front of
you you still are being presented with
something that's a way to understand
what Hegel is calling skepticism here
it's not just a sort of you know
detached well that might not be the case
kind of you know devil's advocate
playing right it's something that that
really does the devil a person so he
goes on and he says it turns into a
negative rambling which lacking any
stable form strays from one form to
another so it's being presented with
forms and the skeptic is in a certain
way you could say parasitical upon a
world that is presenting them with
different options but the skeptic is
unable to commit fully to any of them
and and does in fact use them against
each other to say well I would love to
be able to commit to this but what about
this over here doesn't this also seem to
have some validity how are these
compatible now this gets really
interesting when we talk about the
parallelism but let's talk a little bit
more about what goes on in skepticism he
says it dissolves them in its absolute
independence the skeptic is an
expression of independence but
independence turned against itself
independence with no bottom you might
say and it recreates them and then he
goes on he says it is in fact merely the
contradiction of a consciousness which
is at once independent and dependent
how is it dependent it can never fully
extricate itself the way the stoic
thought that that he or she could from
that world of appearances on fantasy I
write those things that lura sin and
cajole us into seeing things their way
the skeptic says yeah I do have a world
of appearances I don't really know what
to make of them I do have a certain
independence from them but it's not a
sustainable independence that continues
on and on and allows me to find some
sure ground for myself so he goes on and
he says here's where the parallelism
comes in personal independence in the
sphere of legal right is really a
similar general confusion and reciprocal
disillusion of this kind so there's
going to be a similar structure between
the movement from stoicism to skepticism
and what skepticism consists in applying
now within the realm of legal right
where we have a community and we have
persons existing in the community and
those persons have you know certain
legally defined rights and duties and
you know limits that they provide to
each other why doesn't that provide a
fixed and stable framework Hegel goes on
and it says what counts is the an
absolute essential being is self
consciousness as the sheer empty unit of
the person so when we're talking about
legal right there's a fundamental not
just abstractness but emptiness to this
notion of the person why well this is
the price that we pay for universality
this is the price that we pay for
getting away from the substantiality of
the particular concrete community this
is a process that is still ongoing
within Western consciousness it reminds
me there's a little bit of a digression
of a remark that was made by Jean
Francois Ravel in neither Marx nor Jesus
Ravel is is one of these French
intellectuals who thought that French
anti-americanism
in the 60s 70s 80s was actually in some
respects kind of you know non not really
ethically serious comportment on the
part of the French and he thought that
there really was a fundamental clash
going on between communism and
capitalism he was not a fan of
capitalism as such any more than say
social nathan was but he saw that the
French attitudes you know and the Third
Way idea really were not what they
measured up to be and one of the things
that he he pointed out was that the
reason why the French was a surmise of
him one reason why the French he had
such an animus against the American as
being like this universalizing reducing
everything down not just a legal right
but the economic relation sort of the
caricature of the American Way right
everybody is the salesman blah blah blah
right you've probably heard this a
million times before
he said that's interesting but what the
French are really upset about is the
fact that they are no longer the
universal nation and he meant this to
the Hegelian way in the past
French was for example the language of
diplomacy why it wasn't just because oh
it's such a nice language and you know
everybody could be nice nice with each
other no it's because France at one time
was a global power that Europe was
centered around you know Ravel is
writing just a hundred and seventy odd
years after the rise of Napoleon when
France was indeed the universal country
that
almost managed to bring all of Europe
into one great system you know sort of
the precursor to the EU the Continental
System opposed by of course England and
you know Russia wants Russia turned
against it and a few other interesting
things so the idea was that you know as
opposed to other nations France had a
kind of insecurity because it was
already a universal nation it was
already thinking in broader terms than
just what's good for the the Bohemians
or checks what's good for the Germans
what's good for the Spanish was good for
the Portuguese now this may be a bit of
a caricature but you get where this is
going yet you had you know ethmoid
particular nations folks right fokker in
and france was something different
America comes on the scene after world
war ii and the debacle of the second
world you know the deconstruction of the
entire european order and comes on the
scene as the nation that has democratic
aspirations for everybody very you know
idiosyncratic kind of democracy right it
was funny electoral college and you know
people sometimes we're confusing
democracy with the american way of life
and all that but then threatened french
Francois Ravel thought John was more
than it would threaten say Germans or
Belgians or or you know Italians why
because of this this condition of being
the universal the empty universal and so
coming back to the Hegel now this this
whole notion of when you when you live
in a this regime of legal right you are
somebody but you're really nobody you're
whatever you can get across this is
similar to skepticism again so let's
come back to the text so he says why
does this happen he says in contrast to
this empty universality what
substance substance has the form of
fullness and content people are looking
for substance again I'm going to go off
on a bit of a digression when you have a
field in which the the relations between
human beings are fundamentally
understood in terms of what Hegel is
calling legal right you might say a
substitute ability of one person for
another are the same conditions applying
to everybody same opportunities being
opened up to everybody there is a lack
of substantive meaning and people seek
that out they seek it out by decorating
their houses by trying to accumulate
all sorts of money which then they can
put into financial instruments over here
by seeking out projects that they can
they can be involved in that will give
their lives meaning by having children
and then being helicopter parents and
monitoring each little thing you might
say you know if we want to be a little
facetious here the realm of legal right
is embodied most succinctly most
completely in a subdivision of what here
in America we call McMansions
these houses that are all very big very
new on tiny little lots you know four
thousand five thousand square feet and
they're all decorated with the same drab
color scheme they all have the same
little swath of graphs separating them
from the other house each of them is a
self-contained unit you can't hear what
your neighbors are doing next-door
unless you go you know for the monthly
barbecue over there and gossip with them
the rest of the time you can just sit
there and watch your screens or indulge
your hobbies or shout at the top of your
lungs and nobody knows what's going on
and everything looks kind of the same
but everybody is totally free to express
their individuality there's a paradox
there there's a contradiction so he goes
on he says in contrast to this empty
universality substance has the form of
fullness and content and this content is
now
free and unorganized what content there
is is set free and unorganized why
because spirit was providing it
organization and spirit has left that
building it'll come back but it could be
anything this is similar again the
skepticism skepticism run through all
these different possibilities so he goes
out and he says the empty unit of the
person is therefore in its reality a
contingent existence you know if you
happen to be in the fly-fishing and I
happen to be into modeling race cars or
you know just sitting around watching
you know sports all day long or
something like that's totally contingent
you know you you know in the this
subdivision you support this team I
support this team because you're
originally from that cities wound up
here because of work you know again
contingency so he says it's a process in
action that comes to no lasting result
like skepticism this formalism of legal
right he says is thus by its very nature
without a peculiar content of its own
there's no necessary content to it it'll
find content you know when we're talking
about where the right lie you know maybe
we expand them this class of people over
here they weren't included in it now we
include them in the larger community and
we say well we have to you know make
sure the workplace to state for them and
they get to vote and all of these nice
things don't say bad things about that
don't use those words anymore but at all
is very contingent even the progresses
that are being made and this is headed
toward something so he goes on and he
says it finds before to manifold
existence in the form of possessions
it's and as skepticism did stamps it
with the same abstract universality
whereby it is called property eigen home
so the transformation does it's what it
is that you happen to have into
legally protected property it says
there's there's something gained here
here's where it's different than
skepticism
whereas in skepticism the reality so
determined is called an illusory
appearance and has only a negative value
in legal writing has a positive value
there's something substantive that is
starting to creep up here there's going
to be a little trick in the next
paragraph of course so I'm going to be
quite what we think so he says that
negative value the negative value of
skepticism consists of the actual having
the significance of the self qua thought
quad the implicit Universal the positive
value in legal right consists in being
individual in being mine my property my
possession my hobby my wife or husband
my little swath of grass my self-respect
don't transgress on it you know this
whole reduction that we see on the part
of the the American a certain part of
the American right with a don't tread on
me flag you know from our Revolution
when it actually meant something to
basically being turned into don't you
walk on my lawn or say things that I
don't want to hear or you know follow my
Twitter account it's really you know
along the lines with Hegel segment and
vacuous the only time it has content is
when it's reactive against somebody
coming in and saying something so he
says look you know the positive content
of legal right consists in being mine in
the sense of the category something
whose validity is recognized and actual
so property becomes something that is
recognized and Hegel uses that term on a
on account here right on our Kenan
recognition recognition for me as Who I
am something that I have been deeply
desiring comes through recognizing my
property recognizing that
you have to keep your hands off whatever
it is that I own interesting isn't it
this reductive 'no so it goes on he says
the actual content or specific character
of what is mine whether it be an
external possession or also the inner
riches of poverty and spirit and
character isn't contained in this empty
form and is that concern it so here we
get to the point of transition the
content belongs therefore to an
autonomous power which is something
different from the formal Universal the
formal Universal is this realm of legal
right this realm of property this realm
of recognition of what belongs to the
person belongs to a power that is
arbitrary and capricious something that
lies outside of that consciousness of
right therefore in the very fact of
being recognized as having validity he
says then here's an important transition
point experiences the loss of its
reality and experiences its complete in
essentiality and so Hegel concludes here
by saying to describe an individual as a
person is an expression of contempt why
because at this point in the game the
recognition that is being provided to
the person is being provided in terms of
something that can be recognized within
this system but also is not going to be
recognized by what makes the system work
for that we're going to have to look at
the next paragraph